handlery hey you're here because you are
our fallout 4 resident expert here sure
gamespot com and it turns out they have
put at a new piece of DLC new co world
yeah you play some this morning I did I
live streamed it cool gamespot com uh
yeah it's fun I actually compared to the
last one far harbor yes uh they kind of
went all out on this new setting the
nucca world theme park disneyland esque
ok so say a it's like the slurms
mckenzie of the fallout world it is a
theme park based around there coca-cola
no kouko so what is it like what does it
how big is that where is it in the maps
how big is it uh is it in the existing
map or TF like no it's it's so it's in
similar fashion with all their DLC you
start by checking your radio or ok yeah
you find you know you basically get then
a quest which points you into like in
this case it was the new co world like
tram ride that takes you off map oh cool
similar if our Harbor you get on a boat
right and this time it's it's just
chaotic this whole this whole new map so
it's like a theme park that's like built
out in the middle of nowhere almost you
take like a train to it yeah like I
guess most theme parks are ya and then
it's just like what just totally effed
up yeah it's you know as fallout fashion
it's just completely run down and this
time around things I guess are a little
different again I you know it's funny it
actually took so long just to get going
in the new map yeah they have like this
huge I was looking to chat some guy was
saying who's watching smother guy took
like three hours just to get through
this crazy trap-filled maze we're like
you to every corner I'm this latching
was kind of fun I was screaming cuz
there's one room for instance where you
know you you enter and there's a guy on
the speakerphone he's just kind of
making fun of you the whole time and
their intent basically they also set it
up there are I guess three Raider
factions that are diverse and they all
kind of are fighting for power of the
entire theme park this I just love the
concept of this already yeah mr. state
so each
greater fraction is just a group of just
[ __ ] warriors yeah very much so and
so are you like trying to make your way
through this like fun house of death on
the way in or something it's like
they've set up all these traps for you
to like yeah oh my god and so it's it's
kind of a cool premise were they the
radio even you find out I mean this is
kind of spoilery but whatever its
disciplinary you just your lure there
and it turns out that all the Raiders
there uh just try to kill people and
learn them they're just like budem yeah
they're all just Roby's the [ __ ] you
basically like kick off and and they're
doing like a gladiator style you find
yourself basically in this ring against
a guy with a power armor who's like
jacked up on like electricity and you're
just you know they immediately take away
your companion so my robot ADA is not
there and I'm skiing my ass kicked this
guy got it is so good uh ada is like the
ultimate I got a best hack that could
ever have oh my god she's so great uh
she's got a ninja blade on one arm and a
gattling on the other so often she just
resolves fights like with thanks baby
she's got range on my legs yeah it's
great so yeah you could you customize
robson so in the areas of like new
weapons are the new enemies at the new
like what's going on ah new enemies one
of the first things that I got attacked
by was a flying ants swarm ok so those
are cool I can't think of any other
animals offhand new weapons they could
so they right off the bat they
introduced a squirt gun a nucca koehler
squirt gun it has a cool animation of
you basically you know it is fueled by
nuka-cola horsham in yeah it's pretty
cool you pull it in and against this
boss was telling use you know the idea
is that you take away his electric
shield and order to basically then to
damage on ok um I'm really nuka-cola
with this weapon yes it's go away its
water so it fries them and then you can
do damage so that's pretty cool there's
another weapon I users just like machine
gun but I'm sure there's other ones I
saw one in the trailer it's a what you
call that toy with the rubber ball Oh
like a like a paddle paddle yeah I don't
know yeah the bottle entering anyways
the trailer showed it being a I don't
know what's on it but it's you basically
have different types of ammo you can
flick these balls at people that are
like loaded with electricity or plasma
or something
I've gone that yet but um yeah I imagine
this pistol you can like mod and to do
different things I think I would imagine
maybe you know like quantum Cola will
have a different effect right yeah maybe
it'll freeze or something like that I
posted right now it's just the vanilla
water um but anyways what I'm really
getting a kick out of is the map itself
like when you compare to far harbour
where you get there it's like what what
are the gimmicks of that island well
it's foggy as [ __ ] yeah that's about it
and even that frame rate was chugging
here you have there are different areas
like you're forced to kind of look at
like a the map layout of the park oh
where do I want to go next so right i
just finished or most of it doing what's
called kitty what was it called Katie
something right basically this is the
child a child yeah infants area right
mark yeah and what's it's just so funny
like it's a very funny dlc it the whole
thing is infested this area is infested
with ghouls right and there are insane
areas of just right radiation works like
one you take 20 rads a second so like
I'm playing a squirt gun game and which
actually spits out tickets in the engine
tickets and I imagine you get like a you
know you buy a weapon or some like that
later on yeah that's cool you got your
purple paste out of your exactly and
anyways you know you're just playing
these little mini games as like I'm
getting taking rat or go Ghul will come
out of it somewhere it's like really
just like it's like a good juxtaposition
between like totally I like this um yeah
it isn't fairly open right it's not you
could do this in any order you want yeah
you won't fall out for in general yeah
in general yeah so like in the kind of
the main market hub that's all situation
this is so much visually yeah so this is
cool this is so then that then i get
into the kid fun house and it's this
type of stuff you know just perspectives
changing or like there's one area was
called like a radiation may egg spinning
a map were like it you earlier you hack
a computer to turn off the nausea mode
or something like that oh this was
hilarious see all these guys eyes closed
the door it's it's like a rotating yeah
map but I so it's like imagine like the
dumb things you do in fairy in like in
I guess adventureland places but with
like zombies on them were just stupid as
hell right and this one was really funny
so each as you'll see in the gameplay as
you go around the spinning room each
door has like a little funny gimmick
like I open one and I get in and it's
immediately just rad spray my face or
like another one it's um for those
perspectives illusions where it looks
like a really long hallway the closer
you get it's actually just smaller
smaller it raises right it's just it
ends up being not a bar down something
Kevin McCallister just set up all this
[ __ ] for you to come crying to me it's
it's really fun and so that's the the
plus of this is I feel like for even the
price which I forget I think a lot of
these are what like 10 bucks but so far
this is just one little section and I
spent probably a good hour and a half
here cool twenty bucks and 0 20 bucks so
that's pretty fat yeah um it there's a
lot going on like it's just from hearing
you described as it already sounds like
a million times more visually
interesting and mechanically interesting
than far harper was yeah absolutely it
seems like densely packed with crazy
little things i like the fallout stuff i
guess like it's one of the more
interesting parts of it is all the like
references to actual like life and
culture unlike theme parks are so dense
with that sort of stuff that i guess
it's like this perfect playground for
them to just like have fun with that
stuff I guess yeah and you could just
tell the crafting of every room feels
like someone has like gone either way to
make it he'll for you like the intro in
the intro and it's difficult right I
think John Luke was even saying I didn't
know this because I'm like level like 53
years in like that um I guess you had to
beat level 30 in order to enter o'er I
really must obvious hi to the theme from
yeah and I'm see exactly it that's funny
eyes going thank you and I see uh I see
guys look like skulls next their head I
haven't seen those in a while right of
course weighing they're really high
level and sure enough I'm using mini
nukes plural to take them down God so
it's fun and I think I think if you if
you like fall out you had a good time
with it I think this is definitely
something to look into like since it's a
lot of fun I'm excited to be I mean I
actually didn't even finish our Harbor I
couldn't put myself to do it
I just got bored this is something works
like oh I can't wait to like go in this
room you know they do really funny
things where like I got a there's a
really thin creaky a setup of boards and
blow is just like this pit of radiation
right no I'm gonna be there for some
reason sure enough I open the door like
think I'm all scot-free wherever and
then the boars I'll break and then Meyer
lurks come out and a guy here comes like
oh my alerts here's like oh god I just
died immediately it's good money that's
cool oh here's a really good room so
funny and on the stream I was just
laughing my ass off up you gonna room in
gas mention this array no gasps oh man
and um you're choking because there's
gas and so then all these radroaches
come up so now i'm judy knees and then
right away the whole room ignites in
flames because my gun fire is studying
all the gas oh yeah so remediated
they're forcing you to use melee weapons
I got none I'm punching these guys and
then I get to one legend rad roach ooh
it's a big one and I kill it and then
I'm like okay great and then it just
explodes and babies come out and like
I'm sure shoot again its flavor goes
okay it's really a memory yeah exactly
just forget in panic situations which is
what know clearly what they were trying
to add yeah you do that it was like
clever that's so cool all right now it's
fallout 4 nucca world as today for
twenty dollars and on your platform of
choice I'm really looking forward to see
night if you want more see more of that
Rob's stream should be live on case what
block on right now and on YouTube pretty
soon I imagine
you